presque dix mois après la tragédie
ferroviaire de l'été dernier la ville de
lac-mégantic se relève tranquillement
il reste encore énormément de travail à
faire pour retrouver un véritable centre
ville mais certains projets surgissent
et sur le code du projet home horizon
mégantic dont la première pelletée de
terre a été donné il ya deux semaines
c'est un immeuble de 12 logements
destinés aux familles touchées par la
tragédie et s'est initié par l'école
d'entrepreneurship de beauce alors nous
recevons deux membres de l'équipe de ce
projet ariane cloutier président de
l'entreprise les coups de pied et bruny
surin président de sprint management et
des vêtements sur et à vous deux bonjour
bonjour je pense que les gens la maison
reconnaissent bien brûlis sur est sûre
ce sportif de haut talent parlez nous du
projet je vais donner la parole d'abord
aérienne kuti là-dessus parlez nous du
projet d'où sa vie cette idée là en fait
on nous sommes 22 entrepreneurs la façon
que l'école d'entrepreneurship
fonctionne c'est d'avoir des cohortes de
dirigeants d'entreprises donc le
programme élite
nous sommes la quatrième cohorte donc de
la c4 et on salue nos collègues parce
qu'on représente la cohorte aujourd'hui
donc 22 lits d'un 22 entrepreneurs et
l'école nous lance dans le cas de la
formation un défi communautaire donc
nous demande de relever un défi pour
donner au suivant
alors le défi se présente et bien sûr
avec la tragédie de lac-mégantic vous
auriez pu faire n'importe quel défi est
ce que c'est lac-mégantic qui vous
appelle à ce moment là où c'est vous qui
dites bhatiaseve c'est vraiment les 22
entrepreneurs qui ont décidé ensemble
évidemment c'était tout de suite après
la tragédie qu'on nous a appris qu'on
devait relever ce défi communautaire ça
allait de soi que puis en plus on a
perdu un collègue de la cohorte juste
avant nous monsieur guette à la fontaine
des dirigeants d'une entreprise de
lac-mégantic donc avec une entreprise
familiale qui est malheureusement
décédée ainsi que sa conjointe dans la
tragédie est donc doublement c'est une
raison pour s'impliquer et pour choisir
lac-mégantic pour organiser notre défi
c'est d'ailleurs tout le projet
les immeubles où il ya les logements
porte portera le nom de monsieur la
fontaine d'exactions l'hommage en
l'hommage de ce grand dirigeant qui
était un homme de coeur donc c'était à
son image on voit le projet qui est en
construction bruny surin ça va donner ça
dans quelques mois
ouais ça devrait être prêt à la fin de
la fin de l'été oui et comment on a
participé à ce projet là qu'est ce que
vous avez fait exactement
ben non c'est d'aller solliciter nos
réseaux chacun de l'école on a tous nos
réseaux pour chacun vraiment a fait sa
part pour réaliser ce projet nous on est
convaincu de à la fin de la fin de l'été
y avoir aux douze familles qui matin rue
localisés dans ces logements douze
familles qui seront dans ces logements
donc cet été des gens qui ont perdu leur
maison dans la tragédie
soit qu'ils ont perdu la maison soit
pour des histoires de cire quant aux
circonstances sont considérés comme
sinistrés direct donc c'est vraiment
avec la cua d'habitation de l'estrie qui
a vraiment eu un choix quant aux
candidats qui se sont inscrits
volontairement pour pouvoir avoir la
chance d'habiter ce 12 logements est ce
que est ce qu'on leur offre le logement
en quelque sorte est ce qu'il est donné
gratuitement à ces familles c'est très
important de mentionner les familles
vont avoir un loyer à payer ces des
loyers à prix modique
donc pour nous c'est important comme
l'adage le dit de ne pas donner le
poisson mais d'apprendre à pêcher
donc on a vraiment voulu en tant que
leaders d'entreprises et de se dire on
va bâtir un beau projet et que les gens
puissent mettre la mer à part donc c'est
vraiment une co op
donc ça va devenir une crop et dj
paraquat d'habitation de l'estrie qui
dirige déjà l'info qui gère déjà un 12
logements juste à côté
mais il ya un loyer qui sera payée par
l'argent bien sûr il ya une hypothèque
aussi une hypothèque mais c'est ça coûte
moins cher se procurer ce logement le
seul avantage
parlez-nous d'argent bruny surin d'où
vient l'argent comment on en arrive à
faire ce beau projet mais ça c'est les
gens qui se sont rares se sont surpassés
mobilisés on à peu près 300 et quelques
mails la dollars de damas et puis nous
le fait d'être là aujourd'hui c'est 2-2
de décider de dire à la population on a
eu une course très jeudi l'année
dernière c'est à dire aux gens d'état
d'être généreux et donner à la cause et
donc on donne puis on va le voir en bas
d'écran on peut donner via le site web
bien sûr pour pour donner à cette
organisation
c'est des dons don qui viennent du
public essentiellement ouais c'est ça
c'est des dons revanche on recherche
encore des dons en argent est il des
dons 1 biens et services et ça vient du
public mais ça vient aussi de tous les
réseaux des entreprises on a des on est
des donateurs majeurs dans la shq la
société d'habitation québec et la pch
qui ont grandement contribué aux dents
il ne vous avait pas assez d'argent pour
tout faire ça mais en fait ce qui est un
peu le pour l'instant ce que bruni vous
a mentionné c'est les dons monétaires
simple on est en tout et partout on va
voir au delà d'un million de dons parce
que la shq s'implique à raison de sept
en trente quatre mille cinq cents
dollars
donc pour des logements parce que bon le
but de la société d'habitation québec
c'est d'aider des gens à se reloger et
la pch qui est évidemment de fournir un
soutien au niveau de la construction
donc de l'ordre de 4 ans et douze mille
dollars qui viennent directement de la
pch q donc on est encore dans le
processus d'amasser les promesses de
dons mais jusqu'à maintenant
donc concrètement on a pratiquement 300
à 350 milles et dans les prochaines
semaines on arrive au demi million et
aux millions pour fauré justement faire
avancer les chantiers
et comme si vous êtes étudiant bruni sur
wii l'école d'entrepreneurship de beauce
avec eux dans ma carrière d'athlète
j'ai été chercher les meilleurs puis
pour moi à l'école et au panache et on
allait on a les meilleurs hommes et
femmes d'affaires qui viennent d'une
passé des 24 avait avec nous viennent
nous nous nous apprendre les bons et les
mauvais coups qui est ce qu'ils ont fait
puis moi j'essaie de temps d'être un bon
homme d'affaires comme je l'étais en
athlétisme
ouais et donc ça prend de l'humilité
pour dire parce que vous êtes connus
vous êtes une personnalité on penserait
qu'automatiquement succès vient avec
mais vous avez l'humilité de retourner à
l'école en quelque sorte pour dire je
veux être un bonhomme way exactement moi
quelqu'un qui me dit qui est qui et qui
c'est tout à son honneur parce que moi
pour moi on apprend on apprend toujours
puis à d'ailleurs même dalle est quand
je trancherai des conférences aussi je
dis qu'aujourd'hui j'ai 47ans et je suis
sur les bancs d'école parce que moi je
dis des 47
mais on n'a pas toujours on apprend
toujours l'école l'école nous apprends
nous à nous à nous dépasser et puis ça
c'est quelque chose que à monsieur le
marc dutil qui est réalisateur de saw
bravo et on veut terminer là dessus je
vous demanderai pas votre achat vous
allez pour vous aussi je présume que
vous allez chercher une source
particulière parce que vous êtes déjà
femme d'affaires oui et à un autre
niveau bon je peux vous le dire j'ai 33
ans
bon il est large les gens des coureurs
des dirigeants c'est savary vraiment je
voudrais début trentaine 1,4520
quarantaine et je pense que c'est passé
au delà d'une question d'âge c'est une
question de vouloir justement se
dépasser avant c'est aussi créer un
réseau de gens d'action de dirigeants
d'entreprises donc à ce niveau là aussi
on fait des défis sportifs en est
contributrice y contribuer et donc ce
beau projet on sera là bien sûr ou
lancement à la fin de l'été merci
beaucoup merci bien
et si vous voulez communiquer avec nous
la tuber écrivez-nous même courriel rdi
économie à commercial radio canada.ca